and all this nasty weather is not making
things easier for Holiday Travelers and
it wouldn't be a holiday without Chris
Van Cleave in an airport Chris is
currently in Phoenix with more on what
to expect Chris good morning
good morning Christina you know Airlines
had been hoping for some independence
from all of this dismal flying weather
they've been going through doesn't sound
like that's going to happen just yet
United Airlines hardest hit last week
with all the delays and cancellations
it's offering many Flyers that had their
trips disrupted up to 30 000 frequent
flyer miles as an apology and as the
trip home is now starting to loom in
front of many Travelers the weather
remains a giant question mark
this morning the nearly 51 million
Americans expected to travel for the
fourth will be watching the weather
be it on the roads or at packed airports
that set an all-time record on Friday
with nearly 2.9 Million passing through
TSA checkpoints some are still trying to
get to their holiday destinations I'm
really like overwhelmed Monique peruso
is in New Jersey but is supposed to be
in California well I'm hoping that they
put me on the next flight so I don't
have to wait till six in the morning
Airlines took advantage of a relatively
calm Monday to catch up after seemingly
endless storms have made holiday travel
a huge challenge delaying more than 66
000 flights and canceling over 9 000
more in the last 10 days alone when
there's a disruption there is no
flexibility left no wiggle room in the
system to accommodate the displaced
passengers still compared to last year
U.S airlines are canceling significantly
fewer flights but delays are up nearly
12 percent compared to this time in 2022
AAA expects most Americans will drive to
their destination and are finding gas
prices are about four cents lower
compared to last week and about a dollar
30 less than a year ago the difference
between the flight and then the car it
was only going to be like a 200
difference at LAX in Los Angeles Quincy
Jennings feels lucky his flight landed
on time I know that a lot of people over
the past weekend's flights had got
delayed so I was hoping that mine wasn't
and it wasn't which was a great thing
record-setting crowds at airports
through next weekend as people stretch
out this holiday on the roads AAA
expects midday today and tomorrow late
afternoon into rush hour to be the
busiest times to drive Christina
Chris thank you so much